s o r r
y i will see myself out
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
another episode of
yeah you said it you finished the
sentence tacos contodo what do we have
on this episode
great question in the back we have
angela
johnson boom
we have some cheerleading moves
in the bag and then we have off the
table visalus
in the bag we also have your boy
the host with the most you guys say the
least i've read the twitter comments
in the bag what did you say we started
now
i'm excited i have a very funny comedian
dear friend
always super sweet angela johnson thanks
for being here
hello thank you thank you for having me
sit down please thank you so much thank
you
thank you so much for being here this is
exciting i i love your setup i love that
you have a lot of hats back there
oh yeah that's my husband and all his
hats
uh he has way too many hats and the
thing is he can't like hand them down to
anyone because he has the biggest head
of all time
so like it's like to me i mean i got
quite the noggin on me you do got a big
head too you and him could share hats
but nobody else everybody's like let me
try this on and it's like
you could spin it in a circle on your
head that's how big is it
are you hungry am i this week's episode
i ordered us
some gesados so this is our version of
how it's made
roll the footage
[Music]
armanda deletori father of armando
deletori jr
armando junior son of the great father
he's the best son i have
i'm i'm the only son gizo is a stew
or a stir fry anytime you combine more
than one or two ingredients and he's
mix it together consider it a giso
several gizos gizados
it's what my mom would prepare at home
and my mom always taught me
a stew is always better than the next
day so right now
in our kitchen we are cooking for what's
gonna be served tomorrow so it'll marry
overnight
and then tomorrow when they warm it up
the flavors will be more intense
the idea of disallows is purely just to
share what we believe
is is like a true mexican meal at least
at home
comfort food we don't consider our tacos
like street tahoes
um and i feel like in la there was also
in discovery to it
not a lot of people in los angeles saw
tacos like this
the great thing about quesadillas is the
diversity of the menu i mean we got
steak picado pie steak and salsa roja
oh don't forget the children's tortillas
we have a sampler where you get six
different tacos
so you can taste six different quesados
our tortillas
like they're so important to the actual
taste of it but to be able to hold
these stews they're like with so much
juice and our tortillas are made fresh
to order our corn is delivered multiple
times a day seeing the line of people
out there waiting for my food
it really makes me feel like i'm doing
something good in this world
[Music]
oh my gosh look at all these different
tacos steaks
i even got a cheat sheet i'm gonna go
with
chicken tinga chicken tinga let's dive
into the chicken
tinga look how beautiful these are i
mean this is it's just
the right amount of slice of guac little
tortillas they're like
little poppers little taco poppers
[Music]
i want to talk a little bit about you
being a raiders cheerleader
i i think it's so fascinating so you
were at super bowl
37 january 23rd 2006.
no not 2006. 2003 i'm sorry
2003 raiders against tampa bay
buccaneers
and we got spanked royally
it was real bad it was embarrassing i'm
sorry to hear that it happens
it happens in sports you can tell i'm
not into sports because i just said that
it happens in sports you know i'm like
the lamest dude ever
you know they play defense out there and
that's with sports you have losers and
winners
you know in the game of athletics hey
like the cheerleading lifestyle i admire
it so much because you got to be
tip top shape um i i mean low key is
like i i wanted to be on the
cheerleading squad a little bit yeah i
mean i'm not going to lie
like i would practice i'll do the things
but i never knew the names of the stuff
so can i do like a move and you tell me
what's it called let's see you go
okay okay what about this one
um that's just called clapping okay
really good you did a really strong clap
you had a really good form you didn't oh
is that my phone oopsies sorry
hold for sound so here's the deal i
recorded this cheerleading
routine just for you little
action and i want you to check it out i
i want you to tell me what you think oh
my god yes please oh my god i already
like how this is beginning
oh my god the kick
zeus what do you think
first of all you were so good you were
so strong
your facials were on point this is going
on the internet forever
i loved the kick i especially loved as
you did the kick and you kind of slapped
your leg with a little like dainty
little slap
yeah you got to give a little pizzazz
and self-encouragement is what i like to
call it you know
like keep it going keep that energy up
it's like you were proud of your cake
you did your cake and you're like yes
queen
yes i want to talk about dogs i know you
love love love dogs you have a puppy of
your own oh my god
dogs are so healing i love dogs i love
animals
i got my dog because you hear the term
emotional support animal and you're like
oh really you need a dog
and you're like yeah really do you need
a black eye cause i will help you with
that right now
but i was on the road for like what
13 12 13 years and it takes a toll on
you
and i was feeling really heavy a lot of
anxiety
and i um went to this woman's house and
she had a dog
there we were coming to say hello and
her dog walks right up to me and i
picked up the dog
and immediately i felt all the heaviness
like melt away
and i was like how did this dog know
that i just needed that
what did the dog even do like it just
gave me
some energy i don't know what it did but
it was in that moment where i was like
you know what i'm gonna get a dog
i i love hearing your your side of of of
the story as far as like loving dogs
because i
on the other hand i feel like dogs
aren't so healing for me
i have a phobia of dogs which i'm
getting better
i'm i'm overcoming it but for a long
time
like a massive phobia of dogs and i i
think i've been bit like seven times
probably even more and it keeps
happening is a problem right
and i remember my dad used to wake me up
for school like he would grab my
my my knee that got bitten going like oh
like
oh i never woke up with his fears right
like bill collectors like i never did
that i i will say this angela
i'm a lot better with dogs my girl has a
frenchie
and i walked them the other day i feel
like the dogs definitely read energy
like
his name is sancho belly by the way so i
was walking sancho belly and we saw this
huge
what do those dogs call those huge
massive they're almost like they gallop
like a great dane great dance yeah yeah
we both saw it and we like we're on the
same page we i looked down and he was
already like in the sidewalk like you're
gonna cross the street i'm like i was
just gonna say that you know
and i feel like that's how we bond we
see bigger dogs we're like hey man let's
cross the street
he's like hey i'm i'm cool i'm dealing
with the walk if you're done with the
walk
yeah hey real recognize real and like we
just get each other
okay so they say you can learn a lot
about a owner by the type of dog that
they own
right i'm gonna send you some pictures
of dogs
and i want you to help me describe what
the owner might look like cool well i'm
gonna watch your dance video one more
time
[Music]
the frenchie the french bulldog cutie
frenchie my brother just got a frenchie
um they snore so loud
all of your girls frenchie snore yes
it's like it has like awake apnea
sancho i see a frenchie and i think this
is a coffee snob like their owner goes
to like
never starbucks but they go to like the
local roastery
and they sit there and this owner does
not like you to talk to their dog
no thank you my old friend my old arch
nemesis the pit bull
oh he looks so cuddly though i want to
cuddle him
really i want to like put my face in all
of his like skin layers right here
like how he has rolls like i want to
like put my face in there and cuddle him
this dog looks like it starts his
sentences with
back in my day miku
[Applause]
the owner of this dog would convince you
to leave your current cell phone
provider to go to cricket it's like
it bro it's cheaper you can get nine
phones for the price you're paying for
one
the owner of this dog
he's not like that no more
before we get out of here i want you to
try this very special taco
i know it's by itself it's in solitary
confinement for a reason
the one in its own special plate by
itself it is
really freaking hot oh my god what is
this
chile toriado tacos which is habanero
serrano chile and thai chile are you up
for it or no
one bite i'll do one bite i'll do one
bite i was hoping you said no because
that means i have to take a bite
but um like this doesn't even have a
taste this has a
a a symptom yeah i mean
now i have to take a oh my bite i'm
scared
ready oh man this is gonna be bad i'm
already sweating thinking about it
jesus one two three go
[ __ ] it's already kicking [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh oh my god
uh-huh it's right on the tongue do we
gotta swallow it
oh
wow who orders this i don't know
somebody
who hates themselves so before we get
out of here last question
i'm a big fan of you as a person as a
comic
uh i'm wondering what advice would you
have for that young comic out there
thinking about doing it and i'm just
wondering if you have any words of
of advice um for
yes a few things one do you
and do you well there's nobody like you
[Music]
sure we all have parallel thinking we
can all think of like oh i got spanx let
me talk about that
oh i'm married let me talk about that oh
i go
on an airplane let me talk about that
there's parallel thinking however
nobody has your childhood nobody has
your parents nobody has your trauma
nobody has
your victories and be a good person you
jesus
are one of the best examples of someone
who is
a good man you are funny you are
talented and at the end of the day
you're a good man deep inside and that's
what matters
angela from the bottom of my heart thank
you so much on behalf of first week
feast and tacos
contodo thank you so much and that's it
for today
tacos contolo season two angela johnson
have a good one we'll see you next time
call 9-1-1 that's spicy bro
dear friends today was the best i got to
talk to my homegirl
angela johnson we scarfed down some
delicious guisado tacos
we talked about dogs we talked about
cheerleading i even got to show her my
little cheer routine
i know it looks a little goofy but there
is more where that came from
and we also got to eat a super spicy ass
taco that almost made me throw up
because it was so dang spicy
whoa i can't taste anymore i don't think
i can reorder that one ever again but
everything else
yes tacos quizados were amazing but that
chile toriado taco no more
anyway that's it for me i have to go to
the bathroom again
your friend jesus trejo
[Music]
uh uh